if i know
that v equals one okay what's the
tension
and what is this reaction force how much
is it pushing back
okay so how am i going to work out
tension how do i get that from these two
equations
i should just add them that'll cancel
out the normal force okay so i'll go
1 plus 2 right that'll give me on the
left hand side
2 t on the right hand side
it'll give me let's see 2g on root 3
plus 4 times v squared and v is defined
as 1 in this particular case
so that'll be 4. so then you get t
is equal to you divide
this will be whatever it is depending on
whatever gravity you want
okay you rehearse the same thing how do
i get n
instead of adding i should subtract the
equations
so i'll go 1 minus 2 okay
uh i should probably do the other one oh
yeah no that's fine yeah that's okay so
you get
two n equals and then everything's just
around the other way
okay you're going to get um four
one minus two two g on root three minus
four
right you just go from there and you sub
in whatever value you want
for that okay so this is how much the
cone
is pushing okay and this is how much
where is it this is how much the string
is pulling
last question almost there the most
interesting one okay
i want to know how fast i can spin this
thing so it actually will stay on there
right let me pose you this question at
what point
like in terms of all this at what point
would it lift off
what point would it lift off it's
it's when the normal right when it's no
longer exerting any force out like the
cone
it stops touching the cone right so
therefore n should be zero
right so if i want to solve for n equals
zero
equals zero that's what i'm trying to
find right
at that point it stops okay where am i
going to put this into
probably this one this one
because then you're going to get well t
t
minus 0 equals 4 v squared okay so now
i'm going to solve for v
what's the tension g on four equals v
squared
now don't confuse it don't confuse it
with um
this part here right because this is a
particular tension for a particular
speed what's the tension here
where do i get this from this is
equation two right
if you go to equation one
when the normal force is zero then your
tension is just
two g one root three two g
on root three divided by four
okay so cancel v
squared equals g on 2 root
3. so this will be the velocity
i can go and at this particular moment
i'll lift off from the cone okay can't
go any faster than that that's your
upper limit